Let's go next to the two eight one area code.
Who's calling today from two eight one.
Hey, this is Jonathan.
Hey Jonathan. What's up?
I'm just wondering, um, if you personally
would ever consider going vegan.
Uh, okay. And, uh, I am not considering that
right now. And um, it's conceivable that at
some other point I would consider a a change
to my diet, but I'm pretty happy with my diet
right now and I plan to stick with it.
Yeah, that makes sense. I was just wondering
because I mean I know that like I think the
statistic is sub 71%
of emissions come from only a hundred companies.
Right? So your personal decision like going
vegan, I don't know how much change that would
really make.
Well, there's a couple of different things.
There's a couple of different things here
and we don't have to, did this'll piss everybody
off and we don't have to adjudicate it. I
believe that agricultural emissions are about
11% of American emissions. And of course,
um, there is no doubt that factory animal
farming is a large portion of that within
factory animal farming. I believe that it's
cows and sheep are a disproportionately large
portion of that. The issue is there's a few
different things. One, um, for, for uh, grass
fed free range animals. When you look at crop
rotation and the way in which animals, if
they are cycled onto pastures, actually start
generating through their excrement, for lack
of a better term. Um, a lot of really good
bacteria and soil revitalization. There's
some interesting studies that showed that
at the small scale it's actually good for
the environment in terms of recycling the
same land so that it can be productively used
over time, sustainably.
That if you get rid of animals all together,
that that actually could be bad for the environment.
And that's very different than, you know,
this mass factory farming or whatever. So
the, these things are never that cut and dry.
No. A lot of people who don't eat animal products
disproportionately eat things like almonds
and avocado and both of those consume an a
crazy amount of water per output nutrient
and lead to the deaths of all sorts of little
animals that live in small streams and little
ponds and so forth. So I, I basically reject
any of these black and white approaches to
these issues. These issues are just significantly
more complicated than most sort of dogmatists
want to accept. And I want to, I want to really
figure out the gray area.
Yes. That's fascinating. It's a a brilliant
distinction as usual. Usual mr Baklan.
Okay,
sir. Yes. You have a good day.
All right. I appreciate the phone call. Thank
you very much. Uh, okay. That is all the time
I have today. Thank you to everyone who called
in. Sorry, I wasn't able to get to everybody.
That is always the case, but it is great that
there are [inaudible]
more people who want to call in. We will take
phone calls. Again, we'll take a quick break
and I will answer your questions coming up
next